the secret behind any chef's success is
that knowing you live and die on what
you put on the place but it's not a job
it's a passion and I think that's pretty
evidence
the wine label the vineyard will they
stand for this unique it's something you
can't drink lots of birds a sip is
memorable a glass as magical and a
bottle is legendary
Neil snowball is quite possible one of
the most creative one of the most
talented young chefs in Britain today
that is at the cutting edge of energy
exciting prove the journey for Neil now
is the most exciting year across his
cooking career the foundation set the
knowledge is there
so I went cap in hand 12 years ago to
mission works down to the vineyard and
asked for their permission to open the
restaurant but ruse I cook for them and
I give them an insight to what the truth
meant to me what France gave to me as my
bedrock my my passport and then I told
them I was going to do with the
restaurant and my ambitions for that
the truce is a unique opportunity to get
some of the best wines in the world
coupled with some of the most creative
energy food on the planet